Hey look we're back here with some
familiar faces theresa peace how you
doing turtle sandbox games last time we
talked to you your video game wasn't at
yet but now it is which is why you're
wearing sandals yes because God going to
the beach does it feel good ya nah worry
out and done with how are you guys
working on condom broke I was three
years okay is there a bit of like
weirdness having it out there the your
baby you've been working on for so long
and then suddenly and now feels good
this is so good all right you get to sit
here while Teresa then was the game yeah
I like it at last time you're here I am
I beat Mary and won a dollar which I've
framed beside my desk she's too busy at
the moment so am we're gonna jump in and
give it kind of a little primer first we
have any other controller we do have a
narco Joel I got one right here let's go
sorry that was number one how about yeah
so for people which is Christ for people
who have never seen counter ball before
what's the kind of a gwan elevator pitch
me it is a 2d action strategy game with
destructible terrain it plays a little
bit like scorched earth meets on RTS so
in this game you're going to find
airship Theresa is picking an airship
pilot they'll have special abilities
there's a bunch of buildings your air
who can build and Teresa's choosing
which one she wants and you kind of
start off with like a small handful
start you unlock more yellow historian
and they're all yep they're all balanced
together and kind of the fun of the game
is discovering which one's combo well
together so Teresa's the blue player on
the left and she is that is the last
year correct and she is establishing her
economy right now there's economy
elements to this game she needs her
economy to get enough money to build a
cannon which should be next soon wait
what a little electric barrier thing is
those so there's this game has a
territory mechanic which is that kind of
blue bubble and on the red guy side it's
a red bubble and Teresa has a lightning
rod which floats in the air establishes
territory and if she shoots a shot
through the lightning rod it will pick
up collecting bonus and that's not
something you guys added quite late on
during your alpha phase right yeah did
you get that in quite a lot of different
comments thread that yeah we had a lot
of stuff sense since it came out
so that the lightning rod is a I don't
want to alarm you but there's a giant
rocket traveling very slowly towards you
you're supposed to win against AI this
it looks really big oh really well that
won't based on our feedback which is
pretty quiet it's one of my favorite
bowling so and that lot that big rocket
there's another one that's like nine
seconds left them yes so usually when
you see your opponent building warheads
which the AI is doing you want to attack
those right away well watch your right
so they're easier to shoot down but
Teresa's decided to keep going with your
economy I'm doing it's all about economy
right you got to make cuz that the gold
is worth like whatever let's say one and
then the diamonds are worth like 1.5
right right so that'll be good for the
long-term so she's sacrificing her short
term short term position here for
potentially long-term gains what I love
about the warheads is if you're playing
somebody online who doesn't know what
they are if you keep upgrading them so
you've just got one of those ridiculous
ones yeah and they just love it straight
at the castle if they don't have any
projectiles yeah they're shoot it down
once it's airborne yes that's the
primary defense yeah but it has if you
upgraded it gets so much health they
might have to hit like three or four
times actually killed it oh really so I
just used my pilot ability which is
cancelling a cool down so I was able to
use them so every pilot has like a
special sort of way like some of them
there's more terrain damage all the ones
have like a healing bubble and stuff
yeah the red the red player has the
healing thing which you can see
activating every so often oh you're
comfy like I can't get no no it's right
over oh you did hit it but it wasn't so
I should call because I tried building a
whole bunch of attack building oh thank
you scammer so she's shooting her
missiles through that lightning rod and
that's that's what's causing the
lightning to strike which is doing extra
damage how much expertise to do it will
it'll do one if you shoot it through one
lightning Ron so one thing she could do
is put a whole bunch of lightning rods
and kind of an arc path chain them up
yeah and shoot it through and it will
stack up I did what we'll see see how
will that I feel like the terrain
destruction can lead to like probably
two
some real scorched earth victories where
you're like ha ha the valley is mine and
there's just like one scraggly rock left
over yeah was that that can happen and
in this case she should really take
advantage of that because the opponent
has it there so it's hard to kill as a
building but if you shoot a ground out
from underneath that we're head then it
oh he launched it all right I am well
sometimes I was playing on nightmare
mode which I guess is it unlock after
you do campaign yeah and sometimes I'm
getting I'm getting so pissed off at the
AI that by the end I just completely
scorched earth it like destroy every
piece of land that they have until you
hit the last bit on the castle just
falls into the ocean there's a good
piece of crap we have a drone you do
yeah it would thrill that's it
specifically for making buildings fall
to their deaths yeah it's really good
combo with the minyan which does extra
damage to terrain and you get that total
score killers oh here we go it I think
we're yep well I how that lightning rod
is still standing up there like rainbow
wave hitting back almost got it this is
a situation where I'm just like destroy
everything oh no I'm not going out that
easy ah now we're gonna play in a second
you better better stand your love game
okay I guess I don't you talk about I'm
I'm doing great over here yeah this game
seems to be pretty well in hand I think
you've got it almost couple more shots
different things up everything's on fire
although a few bills are repair ceilings
thank you very much that warheads
totally gonna take out when your raucous
and it's gonna take 10 minutes to do
this go on oh oh you have your cooldown
ability ready you should use them on the
comedian Lee wouldn't the laser be
really handy right now it would is a
laser a favorite of yours Danny it's for
some of them for some of the maps that
have like a decent line of size
just suits stripe it goes forever so
you're just gonna for big naps the
lasers really good because it has
infinite range we get pro tip typically
so you just kind of hover those
lightning dealies in the middle of the
air yeah they flipped and can you can
you double up like if it goes through to
lightning yeah the exact oh oh my god
she can use their extra money to build
kind of a lightning path where might a
spinning meaning like multiple lightning
sort of rods in the road to go through
that yeah all right well bye-bye mmm all
right all right I think I was in a play
but I feel like you got to put your
money where your mom bout talkin to ya
this another money match Danny know you
want to stick a dollar on it you want
some odds on it I don't have any money
but I have this busted up iphone four
you can know that sweet cakes yeah maybe
we think that you might get pasted in a
glass in your hand when you use I'll
consider it kind of a sangil bonus oh
yeah that's all I Eric Hayes got some
money all right how much is that one
Bend is our Benjamin no no no it is one
Abraham Lincoln swing and a Miss
Washington no it's not Washington this
no I know who Washington you sure don't
all right I'm s you're gonna match it oh
[ __ ] doubles are quit all right all
right oh sorry I skipped oh we're gonna
battle vs know about my bad my bad man
we need to go back to the local
multiplayer now you guys got all that
I'm there you go well internet
multiplayer to should go around them I
don't I'll let's do this man yeah right
like this one if you win there it's just
gonna me because I feel like this might
be losers oh god lays back okay cavity
crowd like a cross down the middle under
and underneath these two big yeah yeah
there's just a big open space so it's
thinking at line of sight that would be
good anti building stuff I imagine a
laser isn't super good at an tied to
rain damage or isn't it's good it suits
in a straight line though so you have to
i'm going to draw their trailer gets
like a like you can destroy the terrain
every what is it to MIT we
5 45 seconds 75 seconds Danny it's okay
you can admit that you just one driller
because her hair is fabulous it is fun
amazing mom's be good here which one you
guys designed that hair oh that was me
it's fabulous okay you designed
everything right you like that art for
all of it favorite all right for two
dollars good golly dr. Miller versus
minion or two dollars all right three
looks to shuttle shout casting here I
can't call it out here so let's see some
you know they're they're getting right
off the bet here trying to work that
economy like you know we saw you do
earlier how early is too early to go
offensive I really depends on your play
style I think that offensive early can
be pretty good because we can set them
back on economy if you sent off
especially some little bomb BOTS across
the map to start taking a hole over
there supporting my designs um I wasn't
gonna laser that mine but you picked the
fortified ones did you gotta build more
buildings yo that's the key compare our
baby out did your ATMs are pretty low at
this a Blue just for anyone who's hungry
god damn it did you want me to bring
easy by the way Tim yeah no I don't
think so yeah I can tell that all these
dirty now is just like God sonic can you
tell you're in like values he's just
like already towel leaning off the gas a
little bit it's just like yeah maybe a
laser for some gems whatever don't make
no pressure ya later that this now
you're you're actually lemme can take
any damage right right oh why did I put
the thing where you have to if you have
to be the one to activate all of these
emplacements there there's no weapons
that will just automatically continually
fire um yeah that's that's basically
true I'm the closest thing you can think
of something automated is warhead which
venue you target a building and it
automatically homes in ok but everything
is a manual shot basically some of the
pilots have a more possible so
you guys set one of those bomb BOTS you
were talking about I decide Danny put
one down and it started walking yeah
yeah and it put it in wrong place yeah
so these guys are really cool because
they'll walk through shields so if you
place them right oh they counter here we
see a shield the laser deflecting off of
it yeah but you can break shields is it
would it would appear exactly you can
break through them and if you're
building is your offense they'll all
sugar up leveled up it'll be quicker you
hitting that laser I am jerk repair
centers are a good answer to the box
your pilot abilities ready oh yeah thank
you the best oh wait no I'll just take
out your economy in motor car yeah
thanks for that that's good I don't know
okay so they both up and the top left
corners we see that they're each getting
251 per minute so that you can tell sort
of that your equal on at least sprayed
of a crew oh no oh oh oh yeah Danny
don't don't put it there so you might
want to think about shields yes I don't
want to put it he's gonna shoot it all
everywhere everywhere shield down low
it's not active sugar here not one down
there yeah yeah a quick reminder for
that one come on drill blast number 20
always got a good telling me tell you
going easy on me no come on Danny you
know how much dollars is on the line to
let her believe me I want ones of
dollars on a date to mcdonalds so bad
they have so many appealing options on
that dollar know they got it Johnny flip
flops over here is gonna take it from
you you're gonna let that happen i wish
i had this water free be able to eat
wear flip-flops as i may I think one
more laser hit on your head well I'm
gonna so why don't I'm curious why isn't
there like a health bar on top of Pete's
castle or you know like a giant fire at
this point
come on long game real long game great
time it now there's no point so do you
find the players like if you're watching
them play online or you know did they do
the equivalent of like Gigi and then
sort of give it up is that is that is
that built in you can sort of forfeit if
you see that it you're pretty much a
lost cause yeah we do have an option to
surrender and sometimes people people
will do that if it's just not in the
cards in it anyway usually matches are
quick enough but that doesn't come up
too much people people will usually
stick it out usually matches or five
minutes so it's not a huge investment
just to get that stick it through yeah
you're not going to be gaining it's on
the time but I just ride it out and
right also you could who knows can make
a dramatic bid with your shield game and
you're this you pass all music I don't
know last time we were on Danny made
this crazy comeback so yeah you never
let go it's gonna happen again no no
exactly this is air days money on the
line good point marietta high mascot
I've my skin in this game oh there is
Danny your economy is really strong
buddy got twice the the income it's too
close oh the last it oh that was
terrible it just about killed that
Canada oh thank you thank you for
whispering shield this long is nowhere
near game I'm hints we're gonna make my
way out here you do you have a lot of my
window thank you I do a lot of money
with you then bounces and I no sign of
your planes que very wrong flaming
territory with these little clock he's
gonna go for all the money that's the
new wave condition I'm gonna make it
sound elitist all of it my Empire will
be gone but I'll be racing so I don't
care he makes his own win yeah you'll
just flee the country leave all your
citizens to you know suffer under the
iron flip-flop of their new rule
and you'll be in non-extradition
territory exactly I don't know I feel
like is that worked into the story of
cannon bra is an advantage I didn't push
it far enough Danny's healing the laser
too many lasers maybe maybe a shots
underneath the laser tuna Oh almost did
Saul says oh I missed the shot your
guess oh well you hit another laser I
mean that's not gonna be bad here we go
Oh God yeah so buildings fall did they
always get destroyed or just sort of
depend on their health and the distance
they fall it does depend on the distance
so if they just fall a little bit they
won't take as much damage as possible if
they'll live now on the right side
underneath the red castle it looks like
there's been a little bit of drilling in
and same under the blue with that laser
oh I guess this answers my question is
the land gonna fall down under the
castle oh good yeah no we don't have
gravity on the terrain I guess I could
have think you might otherwise i'll be
looking at all the shards of terrain
floating i do have a lot of floating
islands built into the maps of different
levels I don't Danny don't shoot that
but that's for later don't repair it
just shoot my face right now all you
guys yelling thing here's my Hail Mary
here's the cow note from downtown oh yes
go for the castle right on the shield
he's got a healing thing oh oh oh
alright alright you you were a kind man
I feel I guess I know who you're taking
out to mcdonalds day yeah who you wanted
I don't even know what the so because
like a hamburger we fish fillet no sir
very fancy but i only get one though
that pretty good approximation of i
played a lot of this game I realex cam I
got like 30 samara's on unseen my stuff
you guys got to keep doing like adding
more stuff to it because it seemed like
when I was paying John the Alpha there
is a really like good community and a
pack
I know you've had like a lot of folks
coming up oh yeah we're like big into
the game so you're gonna keep like I
know you looking at the console stuff as
well or yeah we're looking at ps4 next
not really a that that's kind of our
next big big push and it's an any
knowledge one will see that in the
future in the future long enough away
that you can relax and go to the beach
and ensure that and stuff yeah what's it
like having a nose not just been really
exciting we had a great day on twitch on
lunch Jonathan Blow was play Jonathan
flow is playing that was super duper
cool and you know a couple of other big
streamers that I'm a big fan of like
swifter and I'm soon so that was really
fun for us and it's been really cool to
see all the people in our community in
our lobby so excellent yeah so for the
folks at home who might want to pick it
up whereabouts is it and how much monies
will it cost them it is on steam it is
fifteen dollars but it's on sale 25
percent off cool cryonic all this five
more days okay cool alright guetta let's
get a lot hot thanks very much guys for
coming on thanks i will see for the ps4
one in the future
you